[Music]
hello and welcome to cross not where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaBelle
Tobin nineteen pandemic not only sees
much of the world in lockdown but it is
also devastated economies the pandemic
has been painful recovering from it may
be even more painful is it all Beijing's
Falls
[Music]
from stopping the pandemic I'm joined by
my guest dmitry babichenko he's a
political analyst and editor at in us me
internet media project and in london
Macross - alexander makiura see he has
arrival on legal affairs as well as the
editor-in-chief of the duran dot-com
right gentlemen cross stop girls and
effect that means you can jump in
anytime you want and I always appreciate
it all right let's go to Alexander
Mackerras first in in London as the
United States and Britain deal with this
pandemic here I haven't I have noticed
that there's a very interesting ways of
explaining why things have gone wrong
and it's a foreign country all right
primarily in the United States it's
China and you have it's a very political
issue because it is blaming China is one
way for conservatives and I'm all save
it is Fox News to say that it's all
China's fault to deflect from what Trump
should have done or could have done in
the early parts of this crisis here
and of course it's we are in a political
season in the United States a
presidential election so this is this is
like Russia Gate 3.0 and then reviewing
the British press here I mean again the
V the deepest most vile rusa phobia
raises its head again I mean if Russia
is even suggesting giving aid and
comfort is somehow a Trojan horse or a
means of subversion here I mean you know
hopefully in future historians will look
at this as the reaction of the media and
some members of the elite were just
completely childish as a pandemic was
raging through the world I mean it
really kind of defines any kind of
sensibility go ahead Alex I think that's
right I mean it's completely irrational
that's not to say that the Chinese did
everything perfectly boss the problem is
that you know our governments in Britain
and the United States had reacted far
worse and I was just reading an
extraordinary article in the in the
London Times
and cataloging the fact that for 38 days
the British government was basically are
completely unengaged with the problem
and
Minister Boris Johnson skipped five
crisis meetings to discuss this so you
know what you do when you're failing
when people thousands of people are
dying when your hospitals are
overflowing when you don't have enough
protective equipment or clothing for
hospital staff which you have in Britain
you blame outsiders and you blame China
because of course China is theme of the
great rival and competitor and it's also
shockingly managed to get this epidemic
under control which is what we are
signally failing to do so that makes us
incredibly angry and of course you also
blame the enemy who is always the
consistent common invariable enemy which
is Russia we just had no role in this
whatsoever so the Russians are providing
help to Italy they must be doing it for
some sinister purpose if the Russians
are doing things better than we are that
must mean that their did they're up
they're up to no good again and we have
this constant pumping out of this
propaganda which I'm afraid I'm sorry to
say this I think this time especially
the anti Chinese part of it is starting
to gain some traction with the broader
population as people become very angry
with the situation they find themselves
in you know a you know Dima reading the
British press I came across two new
terms that you know just this morning
okay some virus politique and cyber
gulag apparently that's what's going on
in the country I live in I didn't know
that okay but the Guardian is
all-knowing apparently here the
interesting thing about China is that
we're working we're seeing a revision or
return of this kind of Cold War paradigm
of the enemy communism the Soviet Union
not our values you know I lived through
it I remember it very very well I mean
all three of us did okay but the
interesting thing here in this case is
that the West under the leadership of
the United States had almost
virtually no economic contact with the
Soviet bloc it was it was minuscule okay
minuscule and and in you couldn't use
that as any kind of leverage and that
was always one of the arguments against
the these and we let's use the term that
we use now that was it was sanctioned it
was sanctioned for seventy years okay
with maybe the exception of the of the
time during the Second World War you you
can't use this same paradigm against
China one of your largest trading
partners and one of the most to keep one
of the most important key players in
international trade and in finance and I
could go on and on I mean you you one
point you can have an emotional reaction
to make you feel good because of the
failings of your leaders okay fine all
right that's so that happens all the
time it's it's it doesn't merit a
rational agreement but that's what
people do okay blame someone else but if
you want to blame China then there are
actually implications of blaming China
and retaliation reparations what does
that all mean in your mind go ahead Dima
well it's interesting you are basically
right when you say that there was not
much economic interaction between the
west and the countries of the Soviet
bloc with a notable exception of Hungary
which was a member of the World Bank
even before 1989 since the early ages
ironically Hungary now is criticized by
the European Union if you read the
negative articles in the European press
the number of negative articles about
the Hungarian government is much bigger
than negative articles about the
countries which actually suffered the
biggest losses you know the most
careless countries such as Spain or the
UK and the reason is ideological you
know the EU just doesn't like Viktor
Orban the fact that Viktor Orban was
more effective than Boris Johnson in in
continuing the disease is not important
what is important is that Viktor Orban
is not our guy and
Johnson is our guy you know or at least
he was until the Branson so basically
you're right about China it is just
amazing how hypocritical the United
States can be criticizing China you know
they the both mr. Biden and mr. Trump
they require I quote full disclosure
from China well when did the United
States provide full disclosure on the
war in Iraq when the wars in in Syria or
in Libya the United States did not
provide the full disclosure and now you
know the Washington Post is writing
China has put a lock down on January
23rd and it marshaled resources as only
an authoritarian regime can well the the
huge problem is that the so-called
democratic regimes as it transpired
simply did not have enough hospitable
hospital beds you know they didn't
prepare for for anything they they
didn't prepare for a war they didn't
prepare for an epidemic they just had a
minimum of beds so that they could
extract maximum of money from the
patients and the system crown but as it
could be expected it's a really good
point because I mean it kind of
dovetails with you your your usual
mantra which I always welcome on this
program is about ideology and you're
absolutely right but you know what
no one's gonna deny on this program and
our viewers are going to agree China is
a very ideological place but so it's the
West okay and in just in a different way
here okay if Alexander because I mean
again the same question to you I mean
you know there's this talk of decoupling
after 40 years of this globalization
with China is a major partner I mean
just get your head around it forty years
ago we barely had stats on China
you remember that barely they were not
possibly the world economy and now
because China is a very
real peer to the United States to the
West it's a peer and that is something
that no one thought was conceivable
forty years ago now before you went to
the question I want to reiterate what
you said in your first answer this does
not absolve China of its behavior before
during this crisis here everyone should
be held accountable wait and we need
transparency here but you know going
from challenging their transparency to
decoupling one of the major economies in
the world that is essentially an act of
war okay go ahead Alex well it is going
to make an economic problems on top of
the health crisis that we already have
because of course the way you're going
to deal with both the economic problems
that are staring from this health crisis
and the health crisis itself is my
pooling resources internationally you
can't do that if you exclude what is by
some estimates the well by all estimates
that will sink second-biggest economy
and the world's biggest manufacturing
power and of course a country which has
enormous financial resources but you
talk about Peter the fact that 40 years
ago we barely register China barely
registered and that's absolutely true
but that of course is the reason why we
see all these tensions is this enormous
rise of China in terms of wealth in
terms of power in terms of global reach
in terms of attractiveness around the
world it is something that Western
governments and Western societies and
the more ideologically minded people in
the West have been extremely unnerved by
and I can't help but think that what has
happened is that this particular health
crisis
has acted as a catalyst for all those
concerns than our bobble up to the
surface maybe not using the word
concerns but I would say neuroses I
think that might be do you really
because the West has never had an
international pier for 500 years it's
something that does not compute people
can't understand it here demon let me go
to you before we go to the break here I
mean also with the demonization of
Russia we've had specifically since a
2014 but I mean Rousseau phobia goes way
way back but maybe in a policy sense in
the sanctions 2014 we've seen Russia and
China become closer together China is
now in the hot seat right now being
criticized and what do you see you see
Russia and China coming more and more
close and this is something that is
actually a function of the demonization
and the Rousseau phobia that comes out
of the West go ahead Newman well
unfortunately this kind of demonization
of both China and Russia started long
ago before Trump came to power
you know just let's remember the facts
you know mr. Obama when he established
his TPP trans-pacific partnership which
then what never came about he excluded
China and Russia from it so it was
supposed to be trans-pacific but somehow
it didn't include two very important
countries you know some would say the
most important countries on the western
side of the Pacific now mr. Biden is is
blasting Trump for praising China's
transparency
you know Trump said something good about
China and China released the genome of
the new virus and jump in here I have to
I have to go to a hard break okay we're
going to go to a short break and after
that short break we'll continue our
discussion on China bashing State
[Music]
welcome back to cross stop where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaBelle
remind you we are discussing China
bashing
[Music]
okay I'm gonna go back to how it said in
London one of the things I find very
very interesting and I'm actually quite
delighted about it is that now this the
at least some elements of the political
elites in the West particularly in the
United States wanting to point the
finger at China now everyone across the
board has to reconsider globalization
because this is how we got here
okay this is exactly how we got here and
and I want to just pick up with
something the Dima had to say earlier
you know it's called a pandemic for a
reason it's cross on the entire world
you can't mix a pandemic independently
you have to have an international
perspective not a globalist one here but
I for me it's very interesting because
over the last couple of weeks in
lockdown in quarantine in my own home I
brought on a lot of liberal economists
and they get they get fidgety in the
hoods that I started saying well what
about you know economic nationalism and
the in the within the faculties the
failures of globalization what about the
renewed attraction of having economic
sovereignty everybody starts wiggling a
little bit of a sweat coming down okay
because these are obvious questions we
have to ask go ahead out well can I just
come back to a point that was made
before which is of course the democratic
societies supposedly have been less
effective at mobilizing their resources
than supposedly authoritarian ones that
is completely not true there is a
complete misunderstanding of historical
perspective democratic societies used to
be extremely efficient at mobilizing
resources the reason they are not
successful today is because they become
far less democratic as globalization has
entrenched powerful financial
oligarchies in the way in Western
societies that are inimicable to things
like manufacturing all those kind of
things and have been using globalization
in order to entrench their
positions at the heart of the world
financial system varies what
globalization is now international
cooperation such as we used to have was
Sauron states with strong vibrant
economies based off and on you know use
it with strong manufacturing bases able
to cooperate with each other in a
sensible way to deal with joint problems
that's what used to happen it's become
far more difficult now because
globalization has weakened economies and
societies and it has also created
tensions in the international system
which had not existed before so that
people now feel deeply suspicious of
each other they're extremely concerned
about what you know the United States
might be doing what China might be doing
in ways which once upon a time would not
have arisen globalization is part of the
problem it is why this thing has spread
so fast it's why this thing it's so
proving so difficult to develop both a
coherent reaction at state level and an
international reaction also also it's
shown vulnerabilities ok anything that's
one of some of the weaknesses that we've
seen in this crane every time you know
john maynard keynes said this is very
interesting about the great depression
when is it when the Great Depression
started you started seeing the level of
corruption the frailties and the
inefficiencies of the market that so
many people worship ok the 22 million
people that just applied for
unemployment they this was something
that had had nothing to do with them and
they're gonna pay a very high price that
I'm on on this program we're gonna keep
an eye on that okay because this crisis
is far from over the pandemic may be
stomped out and it will be but the
economic crisis is gonna stay with us
and it's all because of globalization
and we need to have that conference
demon let me go to you because I think
it's really important to discuss here
you know I've seen in American media how
they get people all riled up about who's
to blame who needs to pay for this here
but there's always the absence of
knowledge or introspection is that the
Chinese government has to face its
people as well okay and when you see
this war of words on both sides you know
it's nothing that you and I am notice
living in rushes that you know when John
McCain was alive oh he would get up on
the stump and he would start saying the
worst possible things about Russia and
then Russian national television which
is subtitling and this is exactly what
an American senator says about us and
they give it right to the audio mean I'm
John McCain was one of the greatest soft
power tools Russia ever had god bless
his soul okay the same thing is
happening right now okay when you have
this bluster coming out on cable TV
it's just be they just put it right onto
a Chinese television saying this is what
they think of us go ahead Newman well
there is another example you know I
think there is a logical rivaling
McCain's statements about Russia just
recently in the New York Times there in
a big article which had a title Putin's
loan war against American science and in
the subtitle in the lead it said that
Putin actually helped spread deadly
diseases in the United States well that
was too much even for the Berlin cat for
once in eternity dossier just amazing
we're getting by the way we're getting
to know more and more interesting news
about the steel doors here you know
Breitbart recently published you know
the transcripts of the conversations
which FBI's confidential sources had
with George George papadopolis actually
provoking him into saying something bad
about Russia and making the link between
Trump and russia which Papadopoulos
didn't want to make because there
none but anyway so coming back to what
you just said it's just amazing and what
is very dangerous is that we found out
we learned from mr. Obama that he
believes this crap because Obama
retweeted this article headlined
audience Lord war against American
science so it puts a huge question who
was running the United States you know a
person who can believe such awful crap
you know how how follow that were
Obama's decisions on Ukraine on Syria
let me remind you that trump so far has
not started a single war Obama to my
mind started three in Libya in Syria and
in Ukraine okay exactly well I
completely agree with Alex I think it's
very important to say that efficiency is
is not against democracy democratic
countries were very efficient for
example during the world wars you know
when you had to put up hospitable
hospital beds for millions of the
wounded now suddenly the richest
countries in the world could not put up
100 thousand two hundred thousand beds
that's just it's it's a shame well FEMA
diamond they might have in the US the US
can spend over seven hundred billion
dollars a year on defense about
non-existing threats but they can't make
face masks okay okay go figure
all right go figure let me go - let me
go - Alex here I think that you know
again there's the elites particularly in
the media and in in in politics not so
much in business because they have such
deep ties with China right now that's
why I don't think this is going to work
because again you can blow off steam and
say you know point fingers that makes
you feel good but at the end of the day
because of financialization of the
global economy that it was started out
in the West here I mean in saying you're
in bed with the Chinese as an
understatement I mean they're so
commingled right now the any of actually
decoupling it which I think for many
industries that should be like
ventilators why don't you make your own
ventilators to protect your own people
why don't you make your own masks to
protect your own people why don't you
make your own antibiotics to protect
your own people I'm not just saying that
you know maybe you shouldn't have
decouple and have our turkey not at all
I just think it has to be thought out
because this that globalization hasn't
been thought out because the profit
motive was always first and foremost not
the protection of public's and voters go
ahead Alex I can say that for a fact
because I you know I'm hearing this from
businesspeople there is huge resistance
to this idea of decoupling when Donald
Trump was talking a few years ago a few
months ago about you know American
businesses you know ending their
connections to China he came up against
huge resistance from that because of
course of those businesses has become a
very important part of their business I
mean companies like Apple and indeed
Tesla are heavily involved in the United
States because there is the other side
which is China itself and I think that
one must not underestimate what a
profound shock all this anti Chinese
campaign has been on opinion in China
itself the Chinese have been insulated
from this until very recently I used to
hear this in Chinese that you know we've
managed our relations with the US and
the West much more effectively than
Russia has you know why do the Russians
get themselves into these quarrels with
the West we've been able to avoid it now
they've seen that in fact it's not
Russia's mistakes that lead to this it's
very much depends on how the you know
what what the dynamics are within
Western societies and it has come as a
profound shock to them and I think the
Chinese themselves are going to start
adjusting their economies and societies
and society from now on to a future
where they no longer think of the United
States and the West
in quite the same way as they did before
as a really it's a really good point
because of the time that I've lived in
Russia is there there's been a distant
growing disenchantment with the West
okay it was in the early 90s okay
and I think that's going to happen again
I mean I yeah I look at what are called
prestigious publications I don't want to
call them out now because some of the
writers I like but you know this is
president cheese greatest nightmare the
Communist Party of China is teetering no
I mean the people of China are rallying
around the flag I mean they get it the
most simple things wrong like I said
when you take this rhetoric the
demonizes their country and you give it
all of them unfiltered to see the
obvious result is going to come about
the don't going to rally around their
people and and and and we have much of
the same way is blaming outside forces
okay and this cuts down dialogue when we
need dialogue more than anything else at
this time well I think the problem is
not in the United States alone or in
their national interest the problem as
we usually say is ideology and in that
sense it's very interesting to quote an
interview to the American Spectator
Spectator us given by the neuron really
be you know the Atlantis just French
philosopher he said that he was only
concerned by the fact that European
values are in retreat and that China is
using this crisis to push its national
agenda end of quote
he was not concerned about France losing
20,000 people several times more than
China and dozens of times more than
Russia he was concerned by the retreat
of his ideology philosophers in the West
talking about values that's when I
turned down the volume and change the
channel alright gentlemen that's all the
time we have now I want to thank my
guest in London and in Moscow I want to
thank our viewers for watching us here
at RT see you next time and remember
cross styles
[Music]
you